Dear fellow citizens, a
year is behind us with ups and
downs, with happy and sad moments,
each of us will have something very
personal
to think of tonight
quarreling with the federal government first it took
us a long time to even form a
government and when we
had it there were arguments and a lot of
preoccupation with ourselves
it is my understanding as
federal chancellor that our democracy thrives
on the majority-supported
agreement that its civil servants
do everything in  those who stand in power for
inner peace and the
cohesion of our country do that they
keep checking themselves to see what they can
personally contribute to
it i have done that, regardless
of how unsatisfactory the past
year was because basically 13
years in office as federal chancellor
always green  d are enough
so at the end of october i initiated a new beginning
and said that after the
end of this legislative period you will no
longer hold any political offices
democracy thrives on change and we are
all up to date we are building
on what our predecessors have
left to us and are shaping  in the
present for those who
come after us, i am guided by the conviction
that
we will only master the challenges of our time if we stick together
and work together with others across borders.
the pictures that our astronaut
alexander gerst gave us in the last few months are almost symbolic of this for me
sent from the international space station
iss there are pictures that give
us a new view of our planet again and again the
forces of nature the hurricanes with which we humans have to live with our central european landscapes that looked completely brown city green in this unusually dry summer even from space
and  d again and again there are
simply pictures of the overwhelming
beauty of our earth
on the one hand this overwhelming
beauty on the other hand we know about the
vulnerability of our livelihoods
and in a broader sense there is the
fateful question of climate change that of
controlling and ordering migration
there is the fight against the
international terrorism
in our own interest we want to
solve all these questions and
we can do that best if we also consider the interests of
others that is the lesson
from the two world wars of the past
century
but this conviction is no
longer shared by everyone certainties of
international cooperation
under pressure
in such a situation we have
to stand up for our convictions
argue fight and we
have to take more responsibility in our own interests
starting tomorrow germany will be a member of
the un security council for two years and  we are
committed to global solutions there
we are increasing our funds for
humanitarian aid and development aid,
but also our defense spending,
we are committed to making the
european union more robust
and capable of making decisions, and
we want to continue to maintain a close partnership with great britain despite
leaving the european union
in may, by taking
part in the european elections, you can help ensure that
the european union will continue to be
a project of peace, prosperity and
security in the future, dear
fellow citizens, prosperity,
security and peace,
but above all we need millions of people to work at home
willingly in
the service of society
i would like to
thank all the police
officers, soldiers, the
many rescue workers and all
those
who take care of others in hospitals and in care on this new year's
eve
the federal government is consistently taking the
next steps in the structural change
from traditional to new technologies
for the millions of volunteers who work to secure jobs, prosperity and our livelihoods and is implementing its strategy for
digital progress with our
work for equal
living conditions, we want to achieve
that everyone has a good  access
to education living space and
health care in the country
as well as in the
city we bring about the best solutions
in the matter more and more often but also about
the style of our cooperation about our
values ​​openness tolerance and respect
these values ​​have made our country
strong for you  we have to work
together, even if it is uncomfortable and
exhausting, where we believe in our
values ​​and implement our ideas with
energy because nothing new and
good can emerge from this, the strength
we need
to solve the problems step by step can grow  and thus
prepare the ground for a peaceful, secure future for us and our children. I wish us all the courage to do so,
together with all my good
wishes for you and your families, for
a healthy, happy and blessed new
year 2019